major what the president called wargames
President Trump has said in the past
that taking nuclear weapons out of North
Korea could happen very quickly this
morning he acknowledged it could take a
long time Ben Tracy is here now also in
Singapore looking at how this process
might work which again could be a long
one Ben good morning Jeff good morning
so dismantling North Korea's vast
nuclear arsenal would be one of the most
challenging attempts at nuclear
disarmament in history the first step
would be finding out what they have and
where they happened experts believe
North Korea has enough material for up
to 30 nuclear weapons and there are more
than 100 sites spread throughout the
country that inspectors want to access
including young beyond the nation's
sprawling atomic complex about 50 miles
from Pyongyang the site covers nearly
three square miles containing hundreds
of buildings the number one thing that
US officials would want is to physically
inspect a warhead Mellisa hanim is an
expert on the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula
she says warheads would reveal valuable
information about the design and
advancement of North Korea's program the
US wants every nuclear weapon destroyed
and a part ship to a lab in Tennessee
that process alone could take up to 10
years and then you would have to search
all the rest of North Korea to make sure
there was nothing that they did not
declare last month North Korea claimed
to destroy its main nuclear testing site
build deep inside a remote mountain
complex so this is the entrance to tone
number 2 here at North Korea's nuclear
test site this is where they have
conducted five of their six nuclear
tests over the last couple of years we
were part of a small group of
journalists allowed in to witness with
the North Koreans said was a show of
good faith these are all journalists
here there are no outside experts that
can actually verify that what they've
done here has made this site unusable
verification by trained experts would be
crucial and inspections would be needed
for decades to make sure North Korea
doesn't cheat with North Korea the game
has always sort of open you're never
100% sure so that may not happen in a
long time now even if all of North
Korea's nuclear weapons were destroyed
tomorrow they would still have plenty of
missiles and ammunition that could
devastate nearby South Korea and Japan
not to mention their stockpiles of
chemical and biological weapons Jeff
Ben Tracy thank you very much Kim
jong-un said this seemed to be a scene
from a movie
Trump Kim part one has now left town we
all wait to see what the sequel is